[Music]  if you're gonna do this  do it right  chart everything out stick with the plan  don't take any stupid risks people die  every day  we're almost there couple more days why  don't we take one day off just relax i'm  sure don't stop on the islands of  despair you go past to paradise the  island the boat of despair for me  on a boat there's one captain  you establish yourself to leave go away  right now she thinks she's got you  wrapped around a little finger  maybe if you weren't jealous you  wouldn't be saying that kind of stuff  about my voice it's got nothing to do  with me whatever magic you think you're  going to get better don't talk about my  wife i'll talk about her in the same way  i want to  [Music]  this woman  [Music]  she's bringing him down  [Music]  she's got you so twisted up  go away you know how dangerous this is i  don't want you to come here no  she's got to go  people die every day at sea  [Music]  you